the course is it's total crap it's
incredibly incredibly basic for a
business owner because if say Spinks
like you need to solve a painful problem
in the market well thank you sir
I mean right no look look I think that
then look see some advice it's ten times
better than Sam's mom hey guys we're in
the studio right now I just wanted to
make a quick note about the video you're
about to watch on Sam Evans it's the Sam
Evans testimonial from someone who took
his course now the testimonial is
anonymous which we address in the video
look reaching back through it though I
think in the future I won't be allowing
anonymous testimonials not because I
don't think they're valid but because I
think they make for sort of boring
watching this is gonna be a much better
listening experience for a lot of you
because you won't be hampered by the
fact that you can't see him so so in the
future if you contact me as always I
take testimonials from people who have
had experiences with fake yours you can
email me but in the future I will not be
having anonymous testimonials I
understand
alex is concerned about it but in the
future that's just not gonna be
something I want to do that said I think
one of the most interesting critiques
that Alex levels against Sam is that
essentially Sam's course is just the
summation of a few books and a few ideas
that Sam has repackaged into this $2,000
course so if you want to know what those
books are and if you want basically a
more thorough version of Sam's course
according to Alex you can go down below
there are links to the books and all of
that stuff you can get it for really
cheap but that all said I hope you
enjoyed this fake guru as always leave
me feedback let me know what you thought
and thanks guys I'll see you soon okay
we're just gonna have to try this even
though the videos glitching a little bit
guys we are here with an anonymous
whistleblower on Sam McLovin for
let me start by saying thank you for
coming on welcome everyone to fake guru
today we have a testimonial from Sam
Evans course now given that Alex does
not want to show his face he said that
well I'll let you explain in a second
why you don't want to show your face but
I am including proof of his purchase
just as verification that this is not
just anybody this is someone who
actually purchased this course would you
like to briefly explain because I think
it's important to address why you're not
showing your face real quick you know
because there is stopping me online on
LinkedIn and all that I don't want
people to harass me I think some
students they might come to me for some
reason maybe they don't agree with me
also Sam is well known for taking legal
action like things like fighting charge
bags and I really don't want to you know
just be public that's totally fine
yeah and that's totally fine now let's
talk about let's talk about Sam ovens I
think it's an important time our last
video was about Sam ovens Dave Rogan
moser is soon going to make a he said he
wanted to make a response video he said
I got a few things wrong so it should be
interesting to see what comes of that
I'm always interested in fact checkable
resources but in the spirit of that in
the spirit that we're all talking about
Sam Evans talk to me
start me off what was your first how did
you learn about Sam ovens how did how
did you get you know hooked in by him
talk to me first so basically you know
I've been into CS for five years I've
been doing sales jobs etc etc but you
know I wanted to start my own thing and
make more money because at the end of
the day if you are working for someone
else you know even if you're pretty
decent at sales you know your income is
kind of capped you know that so and
three years ago I saw his webinar and he
was pretty much promising you to get a
high ticket client in your consulting
business within a short amount of time
like making to thousands per client
pretty much
and I mean he had a pretty solid
guarantee like if you don't like the
course within 40 14 days you get your
money back
and I'll also send you a 100 bucks check
to your mail
now if you go Google actually there are
countless complaints of him not honoring
the refund guarantee on top of that yeah
he does not send the 100 bucks check you
know it's pretty dishonest in my opinion
but you know I think that and so then
one year later I got into his his
program I think yeah was two years ago
yeah and one year as no you saw the web
the webinar or whatever it was right
sorry
one year after you first saw the
webinars what you're saying yes yes it's
been a while yes and yeah he improved
his marketing it was you know it sounded
even better and I I put the trigger I
actually invested to 2 grands into his
course and here's the thing everyone
says that it's it's a great course it's
a great online program but in reality
it's pretty much a business fundamentals
course it's a business 101 course it's
absolutely not nothing special and as a
matter of fact it's just a compilation
of the most popular Amazon books for
instance are so basically the course is
divided into six weeks okay so week one
he is is I think it's my personal MBA
from Michael Kaufman you know it just
saw you in George Kaufman yeah something
like that I don't remember the other but
yeah and you know it's up to nothing
special the first week
you teaches you how to pick an image
that's how I call it and things like
that and then the second week is about
mindset mindset and it's just psycho
cybernetics wave it's pretty much psycho
cybernetics and along with other you
know self-taught self-help books the
most popular ones and basically you know
it's you know if you are into something
very mainstream the law of Law of
Attraction something like that you know
affirmations vision board trying to make
you know a new character of yourself
nothing nothing special we all know that
you know business is all about mindset
right right at your point it's just a
basic yes basic yes even some Simmons
himself he recommends those book on his
channel because they are very popular
and yeah that's weak too nothing special
now wig free is pretty much about sales
here's the thing Sam is terrible
assess is awful and wheat-free is pretty
much spin selling which is very one of
the most popular book about sales and
the techniques are kind of how did it
and I'm gonna help you send me these
books after the show so that I can link
them on screen as you say yes yes and
basically on it gives you basically a
script that you have to follow that you
have to tweak according to your niche
your industry something like that is the
thing it's pretty much question based
selling right where you ask questions to
the prospect and you know you try is
this day lock all over again this is
their marks thing as what your question
I also have HTC but HD HTC I didn't pay
for it like a friend of mine shared the
course with me who has more sales advice
there haha or say from offices no look I
think that then look advice it's 10
times better than Sam's mom because
here's the problem
it gives you this long script I actually
tried his script in the real estate I
was closing for a digital marketing
agency working with Realtors and you
know people will ask so many questions
and and people will tell me look why are
you asking me some so many questions
like why don't you just get to the
point because people nowadays
don't have time for 45 minutes
you know what sales call no they they
have a very they don't have a great
attention span or they're kind of busy
you know these things they hardly work
and just following a script is kind of
stupid because every prospect is
different now at least dialogue says
well you have to you know there are
different kind of prospectuses there's
the third prospect there's the ruby it's
okay because you need to have a decent
emotional quotient just to understand
you know this guy I need to behave like
this with him we could address the facts
or address their fears or yeah yeah
right this is very common thing in sales
yes I mean using a script is pretty much
a quick a cookie cutter approach I mean
it doesn't work all the time
totally cookie cutter it's like the most
basic sales you can do yes yes
so another thing just this just
techniques are pathetic for instance he
says well I invented this a moment's
silence so do you know what do you want
to know what the similar in science is
now what is it what is it
so basically like for example you know
let's say that you state the price okay
you state the price that you have to
stay signing you have to shut up you
have to wait for the prospect to say
something now here's the problem with
that it's it's pretty much an
high-pressure technique okay
and many if you go to here's Consulting
accelerator group many people will say
you know I I you know the silent went
for three minutes and eventually the
prospect mmm hang up the phone because
boy you're on the phone see this yes it
seems like a technique that would work
better in person because people don't
have the option to yes yes you're on the
phone you go it's $5,000 yes and then
you shut up and you just wait for the
prospect to answer okay that's it you
got away but not only for just stating
the price even for just you know it says
you need to shut up many times you you
just need to stay silent okay things
like that is it's a bit it's really high
pressure to the prospect you know and
you won't feel you know you will feel on
depression eventually you wouldn't go
so pretty much weak free is trash
it's awful well cuz it sounds it sounds
like week three which sales is a very
complicated subject they only give you a
hammer and when you only have a hammer
you can only do one thing every time you
get a prospect no matter what they are
whether it yes screw a nail a paperclip
you know a staple you just have to
hammer yes yes yes yes
I mean silence in Celsius it was not a
well-known technique but it pretty much
says things that are not true like I
said I made this I invented this no Sam
this is well known I mean it's not with
it yes for me for lots of things
actually his course he says well on
you're not going to believe when I'm
going to show you because this is not on
Google this is this is not on the
Internet
yes actually actually says this but this
stuff is everywhere everywhere this is
yes it's incredibly basic and yeah can I
say can I say one thing this is a common
thread with fake gurus and my real
problem with fake gurus is because what
I classify a fake guru at I mean pretty
much I don't think any individual course
is worth $2,000 I don't I with the
democratization of information I don't
think anyone can possibly justify a two
thousand dollar course any more but what
drives me up the wall is when people
repackage old ideas and then slap a two
thousand dollar price tag on it pull
from like six books and then call it
brand new yes exactly exactly that's
what it does I mean in his course he
says do not copy because you know people
that copy pleasure its content they are
not successful this is what he is doing
it's just taking stuff from other gurus
other books or their gurus or you know
industry-specific gurus and just three
packages everything and he puts into non
course
ok that's everyone else not to copy but
yes yes he says do not copy I mean
people that copy are not successful bla
bla bla bla bla
and he actually copies everyone well
well
mediocre artists copy great artists
steal
so I think Sammis yes feeling exactly
yes yeah that's what he's doing and yeah
but weak free what else to say I'm just
opening remember dashboard for a second
see I have to say something yeah I mean
and also weak free is very he makes
those two hours videos but he's very
long-winded like it's very long-winded
like
for example one one video is one hour
but that can be seen in 20 minutes or
less yeah and I never see something I'll
give you you know
40 hours of content but that can be said
in a few hours maybe that's the problem
so it pads out it pads out what he says
he's offering but really is offering a
few yes yes are you you were just
hearing again in the game in the game
like he says with his Kiwi accent just
going repeating the same things over and
over again and again pretty much even
again in Iggy I know what you're talking
about yeah yeah yeah I kind of like his
accent his accents kind of nice but no I
know I know
probably laughter listening to 40 hours
of it it's not as nice and yeah it's not
pleasant daddy
so sooo yeah so at what point do you
realize Oh a lot Oh are we are we
finished with the course yet are we
no no no so then we have week four okay
let me so week four he's just some
flying acquisition techniques lead
generation techniques and it gives you a
funnel that says well I could I came up
with this funnel no he didn't come up
with it with a funnel the funnel belongs
to I think it's a mix of Adam's peel
mixed with the client acquisition system
of franker that we you know him right
no I don't know Frank Erne I mean he's
quite popular but yeah it might because
I'm not not hearing properly when you
see me the book on now okay okay no
worries think you might have sent it to
me did you send me that email yet I
think yes
it's not sure I'll bring the emails well
so I have it direction Oh Frank okay I
go ahead go ahead go ahead I'm actually
seeing some interesting stuff this is
hilarious
yes so it's big pretty much ripped off
from them and yeah it basically tells
you you know you need to go on you need
to go on Facebook on LinkedIn you need
to add people and then you need to send
a direct outreach message and you know
talk with these people or you need to do
email a bridge and things like that and
he says cold calling does not work which
is
because myself not work yes so insane
yes he says things like that that cold
calling is outdated it doesn't work but
it says email lead generation isn't
outdated email outrage it's pretty much
sending you know emails in both to
people yes that emailing is like dude I
think that even though I do know that
that like works like it does work but
it's so people are so good at filtering
out spam now man yes so much of it just
goes to the spam folder and now Gmail
and stuff like that they actively filter
for people so a lot of that stuff never
reaches them yes exactly
no I do something more sophisticated
like I send an email they're not called
and I say hey did you I sent you an
email did you read that something like
that something more sophisticated
because I don't rely on just you know
email prospecting alone I don't think he
really works right right and yeah I
basically tells you to just you know
talk with people on social media
in book appointments and closed down
with is script asking 30
questions and what else ya think that's
pretty much it and now we have next we
have week 5 which is about Facebook ads
now actually this is not too bad this is
pretty good but here's the problem so
you know that you know facebook facebook
is gone constantly changing their
advertising platform yeah so basically
any digital marketing course you know
it's always outdated that's the problem
with that it's always updated I think he
copied let me see it's it is pretty much
the carbon copy of Facebook ads profit
Maximizer by Jason Farnham I think
that's the course for people because
look even if you like Sam Evans
basically you can get the same course
for far less just to do a little work
and get some take yeah actually if you
think about it honey mm that's a lot of
the money you can just buy I mean there
are books on Amazon it's 10 bucks you
can buy 200 books for everything mystery
like for cs4 mindset what the do
you buy you know another price of course
there I know I know I'm putting together
right now and actually I'd appreciate
your help with this so uh we can even
leave this in a video I want to put
together a list of books for people to
buy for like a hundred dollars that gets
them ten times the value yeah any kind
of crappy to cake horses look let me
just be real with the people right now
cuz I've actually talked to a couple of
gurus now
here's what the $2,000 course actually
the reason for the $2,000 price like
everyone says oh my course is just so
worth it that's not actually true
somebody told me look I want to price my
course for less but the other gurus when
they get a lead and they actually get
someone to pay $2,000
they refund all like 80% of that money
back into advertising for new leads so a
lot of that profit just goes into
advertising and they're just trying to
so they're able to scale a lot faster
than the Guru's who charge less and
that's when all the Guru's end up
charging so much money's because they
can't compete with the other gurus who
are advertising way more but it leads to
this really scummy system where who gets
stuck with the advertising bill the
client like the the people who are
desperate for a way out of their
financial situation who want to find a
better path for themselves that all they
end up doing is paying for the
advertising to other desperate broke
people yes one thing they will get into
that later same events didn't get rich
from his own advice that he's giving
into this course so that's called
paradox of practice there is a very good
book that I recommend which is called
fast lane to minions which is from MJ
DeMarco and actually sin has copied MJ
DeMarco as well so it's a great book and
I really do recommend that folks about
these gurus what they do and they pretty
much is a sort of fast lane for fast
lane for them to you know sell a course
and get rich from selling courses yes
yes Wow and we will get into that later
because you know you're buying a course
but I mean the advice that he's giving
did not make him rich you know I thought
you know when I was when I purchased the
course I thought that this stuff made
him rich because that's what he says no
actually you got very lucky I'll tell
you that later and so now back to the
online program we're just debunking the
program
and we are a week five yes just the
Facebook ads profit maximizer its
goodbye you know it's outdated even
people in the the consulting group they
say it's outdated because Facebook has
changed you know so it's I will say it's
kind of it's not that bad it gives you
the foundation for Facebook ads but you
know it's it's updated you need to be
up-to-date with Facebook ads and now one
thing about the so this gurus they give
you they say you know we give you a
community group where you can ask
questions you can you can go there and
ask questions or whatever here's the
problem she asked questions most of the
times you hardly get an answer because I
myself when I was trying you know the
same stuff I was following his advice
and I failed miserably with his advice
and I tried for months I put in the hard
work now it's my fault but it's I
believe it's also his fault because they
cause sucks look I I speak with
people that have his course it's
becoming soft cough now you know then
and they tell me many people see that
they do not succeed with succeed with
his course many failed the best majority
they fail with his course and I think
Sam he used to show the success rate
with student success rate now he has
that because it's gone down because the
problem with Sam is that he's targeting
everyone okay everyone
he started in consultants coaches
entrepreneurs everyone so obviously very
few people would have actually actual
success with this course everyone yes
yeah yes you're not very specific right
right and the whole thing also one big
problem with Sam is that he has a very
loose concept of consulting like can ask
you what do you say consultant to you a
consultant is some kind of expert that
may like render some kind of a niche
service and they work on like a case by
case basis with somebody like I would
for me I would like consult as a I could
consult is like a YouTube kind of
algorithm expert because I've done a lot
of work yes let's say that you're just
an expert in a particular field and you
give advice right to someone right so he
says that well you know everyone is
confused and you know a consultant is
you know a coach is a consultant you
know according to him everyone is a
consultant no this does not make any
sense yeah right
it's not insulting a coach is not a
consultant you know these things are not
the same yes exactly and I thought that
that was going to become a consultant
but then he has you know he teaches you
to follow some service delivery models
which are done for you which you know
basically if you do digital marketing
you know what design things like that
pretty much you are you are doing down
for you right and then he says there is
another stage which is one one coaching
you know this kind of stuff you becoming
you start to become a coach something
like that and then there is online
courses now here's what it says it says
ok so you have to go through all these
stages you have to go through all the
stages but you you cannot take shortcuts
like you have to go through all the
stages you cannot go and sell an online
course straightaway
now when you reach the end of the course
he says well you know this is the end of
the course but you know if you're
struggling you know if you are if you
want the boost you can just a brake
upgrade to uplevel consulting okay for
six thousand hey and he says you know
it's it's it's just fine you can you can
just sell a course straightaway that's
fine
she just contradicts himself he's pretty
dishonest you might do so he says never
saw the course before you've done 101
completion or whatever yes in in but if
you're struggling go ahead and sell the
course because that's a fast way to get
money yes yes yes and you see and
honestly you see people taking this
advice because there's never been more
courses from people who clearly have no
experience other than selling a course
like that's like their only thing sorry
can you see the question again no no it
wasn't a question I was just saying you
see that people are taking into his
advice and other gurus advice because
I've never seen more people off versus
everybody and their mother has a course
right now
yes anyone know it's making these
courses because you know the education
industry score is growing people are
just you know making courses on you then
whatever that wherever that is and
selling them yeah now confirmed that
then we have week six a by the way a
player consulting is pretty much there
is pretty much consulting accelerator is
same thing he repeats the same things
for 6,000 but just for selling an online
course
maybe teaches you how to sell a course
yes you have to pay him six thousand
dollars for the previous yes six
thousand and then he has another upgrade
which is one to mastermind I don't know
I don't know about that so I spoke with
people that
uplevel consulting and they are very
disappointed because it's it's the same
thing of consulting accelerator but for
courses same thing just you know so if
you guys want to learn how to make a
course or to you know you know build a
course and market the course you can
just go on think if ik they have all the
other knowledge base or their knowledge
base is enough for you to you know just
make a course and sell it and promote it
that's all you need you don't need to
pay six dozens yep
then we have week six thousand six
dollars I cannot believe that day that's
so yes six thousands but even pay for
that but there's probably a lot of
people do pay for it yes of course okay
yes sure so now we are with six and week
six is I don't know don't remember to be
honest I think it's another part of the
personal MBA from Josh Kaufman I think
and then we have the bonus week okay
and basically you cannot access the
bonus week you have to leave a
testimonial testimonial yes
I left the testimonial but in the
testimonial said ok uh I think I said
something I think it's a good course you
know I I didn't make any money from it
but you know I just make a testimonial
just to get you know the the bonus week
and basically the bonus quake he is oh
wait hold on I'm confused
how are people leaving such positive
testimonials saying how I was made all
this money in blah blah blah when you
hardly finish the court you don't even
finish the course before you leave a
testimonial I don't know
myself I think what the majority of
people mean they don't even go through
his course right because it's very
long-winded like even myself I was
struggling to just you know rewind the
videos and because they are very long to
be honest and and the content is very
it's very thin yes yes and yeah pretty
much that's how he gets lots of
testimonials testimonials I think then
some people they get all excited here's
the problem with is course another thing
sorry is that it gives you
strange motivation he uses NLP
techniques like you will learn this okay
you you won't believe what I'm going to
teach you like this will blow your mind
like linguistic program because I don't
think I've ever talked about that on the
show but it's what a lot of these gurus
believe in yes explain real quick what
neuro linguistic programming is I don't
know I I believe there is no scientific
evidence that NLP actually works that's
that's what I've read
but these gurus like Tony Robbins or
these other gurus they preach about it I
think it works it just you know I think
it can work just for I don't know I
don't know dude I think it helps to
remove you know limiting beliefs and
things like that I can get in the way
but you know it's not a magic pill
that's my opinion
but yeah you the thing is he is very
good at making you think that the course
is great that's why that's what many
people say the course is great because
they are totally brainwashed and they
probably don't know it if you don't know
anything about business or mindset yes
the saying the most obvious things in
the world just sound revolutionary yes
exactly but the second you crack a
couple books you realize oh wait this is
not revolutionary at all it's not it's
not it's saying it for you know
centuries almost centuries maybe I don't
know about centuries but yet AIDS and
they sell their books for 10 bucks you
know yes yes there is a friend of mine
he's read 300 books and he got into
similar ones as well and like hit like
me he's not a fan of him and he realized
he was conned he says well I don't know
how he managed to make me push my buy
button and the course is it's total
crap it's incredibly incredibly basic
for a business owner because if says
things like you need to solve a painful
problem in the market well thank you Sam
I mean we're all aware of that right
business is about solving
problems right painful problems yeah yes
exactly that's what it is
in sports oh yeah because he's just
targeting beginners people you know that
mm-hmm are not really i here's what i
think i think that sam along with you
know that dave rogers Mooser whatever
his name is and andrew argue all of his
testimonials they are within sort of
circle i don't know they just review
each other and because i think that's
what you are doing
they just giris in specific sectors in
specific industries and they just bow to
each other
that's what they do they Brogan Moser
yes a another I hesitate to call him a
fake guru but he sells a course and that
anyone who sells at $2,000 whatever
course usually falls within those lines
for me I'll withhold judgment for him
because he's interesting because he
seems to have transitioned to a
legitimate business I've seen proof
before and I've seen real companies
usually I don't think that's like a fake
thing no no no no no I'm aware of proof
and it's he's going to the SaaS
basically yeah and yeah it's pretty
legitimate he's going before he ever did
that and when he actually wrote the
review he was running a click funnel
thing I mean he was all into the click
funnels and all that I don't know about
his bed rambha I don't know about Raja
Muda but I did plenty of research on
Simmons because I thought I mean this
guy made a lot of money like how did he
make all that money he said legit and
then after my research my research I
concluded no he's not legit is full of
yeah what tell us that yeah you
figured out where he made all his money
right yes so basically Sam started we
was 21 years old he you know he didn't
like working at both the phone and then
he tried to run a business I think he
was selling no I think he made lunch
board for businesses I don't remember
and that failed and he was he got into
debt then he tried another thing any God
in that again where he came that I think
and then he had a turning point he
basically you know he did actual market
research in the real estate in the real
estate niche and basically he DeBell he
purchased a course called the foundation
and basically bootstrap map called
snap inspect and he was still kind of
desperate because I think he could not
make ends meet and he had because Sam
was pretty bad sales so he hired an you
know salient salesman and in Australia
and this salesman was supposed to sell
his snack inspect app and then he found
I think personally I think he founded
doneness they actually bought his app
for ten millions he thought that for ten
million dollars yes
that's insane that's insane sir that's
crazy that's what he is exit strategy
good for him
yes absolutely good for him I mean
that's one a good thing he did I think
he got lucky personally because I don't
think the app was that good because fine
finding finding an 8-digit no pile
that's pretty good in my opinion
that's pretty good fresh yeah
that's me that's just my opinion though
and then um yeah I think he failed to
replicate that because it you know I
don't think that luck can be easily
replicated no it cannot and then he
realized that you know by selling a
course becoming a guru you can make a
ton of money yeah I think he got
that from Frank heard that from info
business blueprint something like that
from Franco and because if you see he is
consulting accelerated group it's seven
years old and he's now thirty and it's
all snap in spec I think that 23 so he
he quickly started this thing of
consulting we're worried he was teaching
people to be on this consulting think
that I don't even know what that is to
be honest if it's digital marketing if
it's if it's coaching consulting all of
them
and yeah he started to self courses
early
I think his foot his first course was
called consulting cashflow but that's
his first course and then he changed
through consulting accelerator and I
heard that the first course was actually
terrible like even worse than this one
yeah that's pretty much it about his
story that's how he got rich from so it
didn't get rich from his own advice
pretty much that's because for everyone
who's wondering his own advice is
consulting how to consult an app has
absolutely zero to do with consulting
absolutely zero today is not teaching
Holly to me how to sell an app exactly
then you might say well if you have my
course you can do the same thing no you
I can do the same thing yet it's
different right tell totally
different and yeah that's pretty much it
about his story I think I maybe I left
something I definitely something but so
let me ask you did you ever try to get a
refund I've had was too late for the
refund and also he he gives all the 14
days protection so basically and the
course basically when you go through the
course basically the content the content
is time locked okay so you have to wait
some time before you can see the actual
thing right right you can get the full
course you also gives the free trial but
you just get the first module I mean you
never figure out if it's actually good
or not before the expiration where you
have to pay before you prefer have to
pay yeah yeah I think I that's that's a
little that's a little disappointing
although in some ways it makes sense not
to give away a whole course without you
know
someone paying I do think if you're just
gonna lift other people's content and
repackage it that's kind of weak yes
that's what he's doing that's absolutely
all these doing is just through tacking
stuff and selling it for a higher price
well this is great I mean this is great
actually this is a much different kind
of a interview that we've had in the
past because in the past we've had
people sort of be like you know this
person did this this person this this is
just a really good critical examination
of his course that it's nothing special
right that it's like a repackaging of
some books which we will link so if you
want to get Sam Evans course and more
you can just go buy those books for like
I don't know 50 bucks or something like
that and it's I think what may be
interesting is like why do you think you
were taken in by him what some why do
that by the coast pretty much yeah like
what about Sam Evans made you think
because okay I was thinking about it why
do people buy fake guru courses alright
you know basically it's so about
marketing they are just very good at
marketing and also they are a bit
dishonest they give you false
expectations like you're gonna be I mean
I mean you when I was watching is
webinar you said this dude and you argue
became an eight-figure he's almost doing
more than me you know the end he says -
Wow maybe who knows I I can do better
than Sam you know things like that
they're just they have a very aggressive
marketing and even this friend of mine
and it was very good he's he knows a lot
about take words on himself and even
himself e-e-e fell for it
he fell for it and then he has for a
refund
he got everything bad because the cosmos
trash well and I think something
people have to know is that it's not
just about someone I mean yes you could
be a fake guru by lying but also by
misrepresenting expect
you're also a fake guru if you make
people think yes oh you know you're
gonna be a millionaire by taking my
chords you're gonna get all these high
ticket clients even if you say oh this
is gonna get rich quick scheme cuz
that's what they do they like they'll
say like oh you know you're gonna get so
rich that I help to have helped so many
people be so successful while also not
telling you their actual success rate
you know oh I've done this I've done
this I've done this and then yes
probably out at the very end but yes
results are not typical but everything
they've set up to that point makes you
think results are typically you know
mean yes yes exactly they never focus on
the negatives that's the problem they
just speak about the people that are
being successful then they say well you
know he has this thing Sam it says well
if you complain you're loose you where
they lose her a uniform like you're a
loser okay if you couldn't play you're a
loser you know I never complained in his
Facebook group it's just I put the stuff
here and I was you know teaching and
four months for me myself and he didn't
work because some things that he teaches
are you know there are so many things
missing to be honest so many things
missing but he says things like you know
that's all you need you just need my
course don't worry about just just
follow exactly what I say okay you'll be
successful don't worry things like that
yeah it gives you this feeling it's
getting to be honest with these
gurus and then they have the disclaimer
and they say you know resource I'm not
typical just to cover their ass yeah
yeah at the very bottom you know
whatever but everything but after that
point it's like saying like yes yes yes
yes you could you can succeed - yeah one
thing one thing that the on the
complaining note I've actually had
people comment to me email me that they
when I made my video about Dan Locke
I've made several videos about enloc
he's kind of my favorite thank you they
would comment on the video and Dan Locke
has been monitoring the comments and
kicking out anyone in his Facebook group
that comments on my video and so not
only is negativity not allowed
like with fake gurus but oftentimes you
can't even be negative off the Facebook
group if anyone gets wind you like it's
like basically like police state if you
get found that you're being negative or
whatever you're yes because you know
it's very cultish you can't complain for
some reason I don't know maybe he
doesn't want people to speak bad about
it and you know just you complain about
him I know it that's just what he wants
to do as he style you know I really
think that Sammy's worse than them lock
that's just might be I know I think I
get that sense that you think Sam's
worse than Dan if you go into his
YouTube channel I mean if you see his
objection handling I mean that's pretty
decent it's way better than Sam seer
stuff that's for sure and it's pretty
I'm not even joking well look I always
say this to people I I have no problem
with people watching fake gurus all day
their YouTube channels where I get
annoyed is when they buy their two
thousand dollar course I'm all for free
educational content that's what I'm all
for but when people spin up bad
educational content and they try to make
it pretend that it's theirs and sell it
for 2 grand that's when I have a problem
and they make false promises to people
while they're doing it you know what I
want to say now to people is that what
I've learned personally is that you need
to avoid all the mainstream gurus I'm
talking about dialog same moments Tai
Lopez alex becker all this mean
mainstream goals just avoid them because
they really don't they can be good at
everything write about sales about
mindset about teaching they can be good
at everything that these people talk
about everything right and even salmon
his course says that you have to be a
specialist not a generalist right right
yeah right yeah he's he's a generalist
himself in himself is he is good at
everything right but in reality is good
and nothing he's selling a course about
no teaching people how to make money
which is a kind of gimmick in my opinion
that's just my opinion Warren Buffett
not self and of course or you know you
know you know I mean right
oh there's millions of successful people
who do not do not sell of course exactly
first thing you learn when you're
successful is that success comes in all
different forms and that often times the
way you got successful will not be the
way someone else got successful exactly
executive OC you learn something
valuable you really tend to not share it
right into Europe in public of course
well and often times I'll say this to
the market opportunities that make
people successful are always temporary
for example making the kinds of YouTube
videos I do was a lot less saturated of
a market when I got into it now video
essays everybody's making video essays
so what I recommend that somebody just
run and dive headfirst into video essays
I wouldn't discourage them but I
wouldn't pretend that you can achieve
success by just copying every video that
I've ever done it's like things there
are limited windows and windows of
opportunity so anyone promising a path
they call it a path to success or a
system of success is what they like to
say they imply it falsely implies that
success can be systematized when in
reality success is not penalizing on
market opportunities that are temporary
accept it and if you know if a good
assassin course about an opportunity
that think knowing will eventually get
saturated right of course by definition
yeah yeah and once one piece of advice
that I can give you guys is that if you
want to follow gurus there are great
gurus but they're not really you know
this mainstream gurus give you an
example let's say you want to learn
about sales right just go for the ones
that are just good at something for
example Brian Tracy for sales or Jeremy
miner
you know things like that just go for
the people you know they don't give
mainstream advice to everyone
it's just you know very niche especially
specific do you know what I mean yeah
they don't spend millions of ads
promising lies yes yeah you know
promoting lifestyle or promising you of
making your agents it's all
just
don't fall for it yeah that's good
advice that's good advice
hey I think that's about good I think we
pretty much covered everything do you
have anything else you want to add as a
final thing I think myself personally
this trend of the fakers is going to get
bigger so be prepared because if you
remember four years ago um ty Lopez
rented a Lamborghini right now I see
these gurus they are renting everything
that they are targeting very
sophisticated it's going to get worse
because I I saw one guy is selling you
know forex courses something like that
he's renting models you know cars
employees like everything is faking
everything it's getting even the the
industry of papers is getting
competitive it's just going to get worse
you guys need to be careful they're just
going to be more sophisticated and just
stay away from them that's what I say
even if it sounds too good to be true it
generally is trust me - good to be true
dude that's what I always say people
hang on to hope and they say well maybe
this is the one yeah yeah
no nothing's too good to be true
everything has a catch and I don't I
think that is cynicism you know it is
like there are there are great things
out there but none of them are like
without their downfalls
I think that's it I think that's I think
we've pretty much covered everything
st. thank you so much Alex for coming on
and talking about your honest experience
with Sam Evans I think no matter what no
matter what you believe about him I
think everyone can learn something from
the other side of the story all we hear
all the time is the positive reviews of
Sam Evans which are obviously
incentivized by this extra week that has
promised people who get leave
testimonials so I really appreciate
hearing the other side of the story and
yeah thanks for coming on we're
definitely going to leave a lot of
footnotes for where you can find these
books where you can find you know
basically Sam's whole course it but in a
much cheaper form and from the original
sources
themselves yes no problem I will do that
if you guys need you know you know
you're pretty much a cheap version of
the consulting accelerate or I'll I'll
tell you the books and all the courses
etc no worries thanks for coming on the
show anybody who wants to do the same
anyone who has an experience with one of
their fake gurus leave me a message go
email me that's how Alex got ahold of me
email me tell me you want to come on the
show I think people really enjoy this
stuff so yeah anyway thanks guys thanks
for watching we'll see you next
[Music]
but never to the trust